Siana Taylor's sold the show with her
booty-popping performance and Kanye
West's premiere at the 2016 VMAs it's
clear Tiana's moves are hypnotizing and
she's insanely fit but here's why the
star of Yeezys new fade video was so
familiar the 25 year old singer rose to
fame after being signed to Pharrell
Williams record label at 15 and starred
on an episode of MTV's my super sweet 16
it's the word I'm the word on the street
and nobody has any brother stay with me
Kanye later signed her to good music in
2012 she's a native New Yorker and
engaged to fiance Iman Shumpert the NBA
star proposed back in November 2015 with
this gorgeous sparkler the couple shares
an adorable daughter
Iman jr. yana shared via instagram how
their baby girl made quite the entrance
into the world revealing she had an
emergency home birth and her fiance
helped deliver their first child and
last the proud mom had one of the best
snapback games ever
check out her incredible post-baby body
just six days after giving birth goals